[Musique]
bienvenue paris saclay tv c'est toute
l'actualité de votre territoire un
territoire en pleine reconstruction il
accueillera bientôt l'institut de
recherche du laboratoire servier qui
doit ouvrir ses portes fin 2021 début
autre chantier ambitieux la construction
de deux bâtiments par la société de la
tour eiffel à la clé 13 12 m² de bureaux
activités et restaurants paris saclay
innove aussi avec le premier réseau de
chaleur et de froid de cinquième
génération en france
il a été inauguré par françois de rugy
le ministre de la transition écologique
et solidaire
mode d'emploi à suivre autre nouveauté
votre territoire lance le guichet unique
cette plateforme en ligne rassemble 3500
hébergement pour la prochaine rentrée
universitaire voilà qui va simplifier la
vie des étudiants enfin notre agenda ce
sera la fin de cette émission
[Musique]
c'est parti la construction du futur
institut de recherche du laboratoire
servier a commencé ceux ci réunira les
600 chercheurs du groupe d'ici à 2022
pour servier paris saclay était une
évidence vous allez l'entendre et tout a
été conçu dans une démarche
environnementale
[Musique]
cette journée est extrêmement important
c'est vraiment une étape clé dans un
projet qui dure déjà maintenant depuis
quatre cinq ans nos ambitions sur ce
territoire sont dire est très importante
ça explose de structurer le choix désir
de venir s'associer aux entreprises
existantes à celles à venir
les universités les grandes écoles sont
sur le plateau de saclay parce que sa
rentrée complètement en synergie avec le
projet de recherche servier qui était de
rassembler nos équipes sur un même site
et de continuer à promouvoir la
recherche ouverte avec évidemment les
partenaires locaux
et puis après bien au delà mondiaux on a
aussi construit ce site de façon à
pouvoir accueillir beaucoup de
chercheurs et collaborateurs de
l'extérieur de partenaires de
l'extérieur et enfin je dirais la cerise
sur le gâteau c'est la partie hôtel à
projet de ce
de ce projet instituts de recherche
servier paris saclay qui va permettre à
de jeunes pousses des start up des
biotech que nous rejoindre à l'intérieur
du cluster servier qui lui-même est à
l'intérieur du kloster paris saclay
[Musique]
c'est vraiment le projet de jean michel
wilmotte qui a le mieux capturer les
intuitions les envies de nos chercheurs
on veut s'inscrire complètement sur
l'histoire de ce plateau de saclay qui a
d'abord une histoire agricole de
fertilisation et comme l'a expliqué
notre président plus tôt ce matin
c'est après la fertilisation des sols
c'est la fertilisation de la
l'innovation et on veut que ce projet
s'inscrit aussi dans cette dimension là
donc c'est extrêmement éco responsable
on veut une empreinte co2 minimum
éventuellement même positive pour pour
ce site avec énormément de
végétalisation des surfaces d énorme
jardin entre les bâtiments un jardin
central qui est propice à la réflexion à
les changes et à l'ouverture d'esprit
entre le printemps et l'automne 2022 on
aura intégré toutes les équipes et elles
seront pleinement fonctionnel sur ce
merveilleux kloster
[Musique]
un autre chantier ambitieux est en cours
sur le parc eiffel paris saclay ce
bâtiment de 13 mille mètres carrés
accueillera les équipes du bm et de la
communauté d'agglomération de paris
saclay thomas georges ans le pdg de la
société de la tour eiffel
il nous explique pourquoi ce site est
stratégique
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on est sur le parc eiffel
paris saclay qui est un parc d'activités
mixtes entre bureaux et activités et qui
appartient la société de la tour eiffel
depuis de nombreuses années la société
la tour eiffel est une foncière de
bureaux cotée en bourse qui a comme
actionnaire majorité indienne
d'assurance qu'il a et ses mains et qui
travaille sur les territoires de manière
profonde et long terme c'est à dire que
quand on est sur un territoire on va y
rester pendant 35 ans temps sans
problème aujourd'hui en fait un
événement très particulier qu'est la
pose de la première pierre d'un chantier
très important pour nous qui est un
ensemble de deux bâtiments qui fait en
tout treize mille mètres carrés de
bureaux
ces treize mille mètres carrés de
bureaux dont on pose la première pierre
sont entièrement loués en l'état futur
d'achèvement à deux locataires
principaux la communauté d'agglomération
la cps et ibm pour installer son centre
de recherche en intelligence
artificielle
on s'est dit qu'il y avait quelque chose
de très intéressant et qui est assez
rare en immobilier c'est à la fois un
tissu local de petites entreprises qui
peuvent être intéressés de se loger pour
un loyer plutôt compétitifs et à la fois
du fait évidemment du grand projet de
cluster porté par l'état et les
collectivités ici des sociétés d'ordre
national beaucoup plus
j'illustre est clairement avec des
loyers un petit peu plus clair aussi et
7-7 double population de locataires elle
est très importante pour nous parce
qu'elle nous permet de faire plaisir en
fin de de loger à la fois les
entreprises de paix de petites et
moyennes entreprises
et puis évidemment des grands leaders
nationaux l'achèvement de ce bâti de ses
bâtiments il va avoir lieu autour de
l'été prochain en 2020 donc on a des
idées de d'extension du parc on va
évidemment travailler main dans la main
avec l'établissement public s'est déjà
des choses qui se font aujourd'hui avec
les collectivités locales
parce qu on est très respectueux des
trame urbaine de la volonté de mixité de
la capacité à offrir aussi des services
et pour les collaborateurs des
entreprises qu'on loge ici mais aussi
pourquoi pas pour les habitants du
quartier de manière plus large
notre volonté aussi c'est en tant que
son sirh de long terme apporter être
contributeurs
d'un volet économique qui est gardé les
start up qui sont un cube et dans les
universités les grandes écoles du
plateau de saclay et leur proposer de
pouvoir rester sur le plateau parce que
forcément elle s'y plaisent mais elle
aurait peut-être la tentation en manque
d'offre locative de partir ailleurs en
france
pour nous c'est un enjeu aussi de
responsabilisation de la foncière que
nous sommes que d'apporter des solutions
de conservation de ces startups sur le
territoire
c'est le premier réseau de froid et de
chaleur de cinquième génération en
france il vient d'être inaugurée par
françois de rugy
le ministre de la transition écologique
et solidaire ce réseau va irriguer les
quelques deux millions de mètres carrés
du campus urbain de paris saclay avec
une majorité des énergies locales et
renouvelables
voilà qui va permettre de réduire 6100
tonnes de co2 par an
[Musique]
dans le cadre de l'opération d'intérêt
national paris saclay l'état souhaité
faire de ce territoire un démonstrateur
de la ville durable et à ce titre le
père atterrit saclay mène plusieurs
actions emblématiques dont le réseau des
changes de chaleur de froid qui est une
composante majeure de la stratégie
énergétique déployés ici sur le campus
urbain puisque ce réseau d'échangés
chaleureux le fawe être le maillon
central de toute la chaîne énergétique
avec du couplage sur les réseaux
électriques
l'intégration de panneaux
photovoltaïques à terme et aussi la
valorisation de ressources agricoles
ce réseau des chances de chaleur et de
froid s'articule autour d'une boucle
tempéré une boucle tempéré qui va à
partir de
d'une installation centralisée va capter
la chaleur issue de la géothermie donc
qui vient de la nappe de l'albien à 700
mètres de profondeur et ensuite la
boucle d'eau tempérée va emmener les
calories sur différentes sous-station de
10 lots qui sont situées en sous-sol de
grands bâtiments du campus urbain et
dans ces sous stations du lot des
thermes au frigo pont vont à partir des
30 degrés de la boucle d'eau tempérée
vont faire du show à 60 degrés et du
foie à 7 degrés et ce show et se fasse
ensuite distribués aux bâtiments de
chaque îlot dans chaque quartier
rien n'est perdu les bâtiments en fait
échanges leur énergie c'est un bâtiment
qui va avoir des besoins de froid va
être en fait indirectement un producteur
de chaux pour un bâtiment voisin qui lui
va avoir des besoins de chauffage ou
d'eau chaude sanitaire et en même temps
le réseau permettent de récupérer aussi
toutes les énergies du territoire donc
la géothermie on l'a dit aimé aussi d
énergie de récupération de la chaleur
fatale par exemple de supercalculateurs
ou d'autres grandes infrastructures
scientifiques qui sont présentes ici sur
le territoire
aujourd'hui on a déjà une douzaine de
bâtiments raccordés sur le réseau des
grandes écoles centrale supélec institut
mines télécom des résidences étudiantes
qui accompagnent ces écoles on a aussi
déjà deux hôtels des commerces
très bientôt on va avoir des logements
familiaux à la rentrée qui vont qui vont
être alimentés et à terme ce sera une
centaine de bâtiments sur le campus qui
seront alimentées en show est en froid
avec une énergie à plus de 60 %
d'origine renouvelable ou de
récupération
[Musique]
paris saclay innove avec le guichet
unique c'est une première en france
cette plateforme en ligne rassemble 3500
hébergement pour la prochaine rentrée
universitaire une solution innovante
donc qui va permettre de centraliser les
demandes des étudiants tout de suite les
explications d'alexandre aux miss
directeur général du crous de versailles
[Musique]
aujourd'hui nous venons signé la
convention du guichet unique paris
saclay qui est un outil un petit peu
innovant dans le monde de la résidence
universitaire puisqu'il s'agit de faire
en sorte que sur un site donné qui est
le site paris saclay des étudiants n'est
qu'un seul point d'accès pour faire
toutes leurs demandes de logement quel
que soit l'établissement dans lequel ils
sont censés étudié l'année prochaine
donc à travers ce site c'est la
rencontre à la fois des opérateurs c'est
à dire les gestionnaires et ceux qui ont
construit les résidences la rencontre
des établissements qui sont à qui
accueillent ces étudiants sur le site et
des étudiants afin qu'ils formulent des
demandes en fonction des établissements
dans lesquels il souhaite être inscrits
l'année prochaine très concrètement le
principe est le suivant un étudiant qui
par exemple vient de sortir de prépa y
vient de réussir ces concours et qui
potentiellement peut être inscrit sur
une école du plateau va se connecter sur
ce guichet unique et faire sa demande en
disant je veux tel résidence et
j'appartiens tel établissement
l'établissement va recevoir cette
demande et dire effectivement cet
étudiant est inscrit chez nous fait
partie de notre public prioritaire c'est
à dire qu'on souhaite absolument qu'il
soit logé sur le plateau et va renvoyer
cette information au guichet qui va dire
dans ces cas-là il ya adéquation entre
la demande et l'étudiant le souhait des
talismans de l'accueillir et la
possibilité d'avoir un logement dans une
résidence adaptée et donc la conjonction
de ces trois facteurs à faire que
l'étudiant va recevoir instantanément
une proposition de logement là où il a
souhaité
les logements sont de différentes
typologies donc vous avez le classique
t1 c'est à dire le suivi individuel
complètement équipé bien entendu vous
avez des solutions de colocation à
plusieurs en général trois ou quatre
personnes dans des logements qui sont du
coup un petit peu plus grands aideront
lesquels on partage soit à la fois la
cuisine une ou deux salles de bain en
fonction du nombre d'étudiants qui a
dans dans le secteur et puis il a
entendu tous les autres espaces communs
puisqu'il faut savoir que les résidents
y compris sur le plateau de saclay
propose un panel large de services que
ce soit la halle a pris les salles de
musique les salles de sport et bien
entendu toutes les installations qui
sont construits sur le plateau qu'elles
soient culturelles ou sportives sont
elles aussi mutualisés part étant
étudiant qui sont logés ici de
bénéficier de toutes ces services qui
qu'on le trouve sur l'ensemble du
territoire
et bien entendu un certain nombre de
solutions de restauration proposé que ce
soit les restaurants universitaires
classiques du crous qui ont beaucoup
évolué depuis ce qu'on a connu dans les
années 50
et puis aussi incertain de solutions de
proximité à la fois en termes de
cafétéria qu'une distribution
automatique le service d'ailleurs le
guichet unique l'outil informatique sera
disponible dès la mi juin de façon à
permettre à ceux qui sortent de sorte de
concours ou vont bientôt arriver sur le
sur le secteur de faire leurs demandes
dans les dix jours qui viennent
[Musique]
notre agenda à présent le 4 juillet
c'est la soirée de la french tech paris
saclay rendez vous est donné à la
terrasse discovery plus x start peur et
entrepreneurs du territoire pensez à
vous inscrire
vous avez des idées innovantes en santé
bien donnez vie à votre projet en
participant au hackaton prévention en
santé
lassé du 5 au 7 juillet place de la
porte de versailles
à noter sur votre agenda cette
exposition lumières sur versailles des
tableaux photographiques de vincent
chauvet c'est à voir au 2 bis avenue de
paris à versailles et c'est jusqu'au 14
juillet enfin vous avez encore un peu de
temps pour découvrir la quatrième
édition de partager votre talent une
trentaine de passionnés ont répondu à
l'appel
vous pouvez découvrir leur art leur
création de leur savoir faire c'est
jusqu'au 3 juillet et c'est à la
médiathèque françois-mitterrand
désunissent voilà c'est la fin de cette
édition merci à vous de l'avoir suivi
pour plus d'information notre site
le pap est ce point fr ou encore tv 78 à
très bientôt
[Musique]